we're at the beginning of April 2018 so
it's time for another monthly update
video and which i'll talk about what
went on in March and what we've got
coming up this month of April I always
like to begin by highlighting three big
things that either you might have missed
or are coming up and you'd be interested
in so here they are big thing number one
I did a bookshelf tour video so if you
missed that you probably want to check
it out if you've got an interest in that
sort of thing big thing number two I had
my first television appearance here on a
local news channel on the ask the expert
segment I'll talk about that in the
March portion and big thing number three
I started a new type of video short
answers for common questions so I did
four of those videos you might want to
check those out as well so what went on
in March it was not as productive a
month as I had hoped in part because I
was struggling with an illness that
turns out to be a flu that lasts for
quite a while
and my wife has also been sick both of
us you know trying to keep up with work
and in my case what I found is that I
would get a bit of work done or I would
exercise and then I would just be
totally exhausted unable to concentrate
unable to get other things done so by
the end of the month I'm still sick now
and I still still kind of watch it I got
to the point where I'd figured out that
I needed to marshal my my energies and
prioritize but I went through a lot of
you know planning to get things done and
then being surprised that that I simply
did not have the the you know presence
of mind or the energy to actually
accomplish those so it was it was kind
of a low-key month in some respects I
did have quite a few events in in our
worlds of speculative fiction series I
discussed Robert Heinlein we focused in
particular on Starship Troopers and the
moon is a harsh mistress and discussed a
few other books we also had our
very first Milwaukee Sofia chapter event
we had two parts event what the first
part was sort of a community discussion
worry entered around justice and
kindness the the the sort of guiding
idea was we're to justice and kindness
meet up with each other and then the
second part of it I led the the people
who attended through a look at Cicero's
on duties and how justice and kindness
intersect in that work it and fit into
the virtues then a little bit later I
paired up with Scott to rule II and we
went on to Scott Perry's creative stoic
and we did a round table on stoicism and
creativity so that that was kind of fun
I also you know had a few other online
events you know I did my monthly ask me
anything session very well attended a
lot of good questions I also did my two
philosophy pop ups you know one in
YouTube live one in Facebook live and I
held my half-hour Hagel sessions the
public one for everybody and the patreon
exclusive one we had some good
discussions and those and then finished
up the month with a great discussion of
Seneca at the MKE and that's Milwaukee
stoic fellowship which meets every month
here in Shorewood so that was you know
the the events and that's actually quite
a bit now that I think about it and I
had my Marist online class world views
and values get started by the way if
you're interested in that class I have
an earlier version of it - the homework
it's not for credit available in our
reason I own Academy I'll put a link to
that below and actually you add a little
thing here as a card for it as well if
you're interested in taking that that
online class so I started about with my
students there they're off to you know a
good clip most of them I also did a lot
of consulting work over the course of
this last month on a variety of
different projects
tutorial sessions and did some
philosophical counseling and some
coaching as well I got almost no writing
done that I intended to that was one of
the casualties of being ill and that
that hopefully I'm gonna get to this
month I did you know have a few other
shows and podcasts come out so I did
some interviews you can see those link
to below
I should mention though the channel for
ask the expert segment so that was going
on on TV and it was really an
interesting experience it's one thing to
be like you know right here in front of
a camera talking on YouTube it's another
thing to be in the studio knowing that
you have 90 seconds to try to get your
message across and the lights are there
and you know everything is you know very
sort of set out in terms of its
scheduling and and you know you've got
to move from segment to segment it was
really an interesting experience so I
think I'll do some writing about that
but if you want to see the segments they
asked me you know what is philosophy how
can it help you I gave some answers to
that you can see that linked below as
well the other thing that I did
accomplish during March was video
production I did not get as much done as
I had hoped
oftentimes I'll schedule because of the
lighting I'll schedule my video
production for the morning or for the
evening and by most evenings I was just
cashed out so as I mentioned I did have
the bookshelf tour video which I
released just a few days ago I I did get
managed to get one big you know
household chore done that had been
hanging for a long time and that was to
put my bookshelves in order or rather
our bookshelves because it's it's the
collection that that my wife and I have
put together and I called some volumes
we might be doing some giveaways with
those in in the near future
I'll have to think about exactly how I'm
going to do that and I put them finally
into a more or less rational order and
then I shot a video of it because people
have been asking for that for
very long time you know show us what's
on your shelves so that that's what I
did
I I did get five of the half-hour
Haegele videos I usually try to get six
done a month but I only got five god I
did some Cicero core concepts we're
almost done with on duties at this point
just have a few more to go
I did two interview videos one of which
I had done earlier back in the the
winter but only released because I had
to you know get get the person who I was
interviewing Matt flam to sign off on it
that was about Santayana
and then I did another one with a local
grad student who's got a really really
interesting project a Sean Miller and
talking about his dissertation research
on section on sex education and and
moral theories and then I did some you
know some some some other things the
event videos but I also want to mention
the Q&A videos so I started doing these
short videos you know ant answers for
common commonly asked questions and I
wanted to do this in part because I saw
people asking the same questions over
and over and over again so it's a useful
thing to have out there and I started
with stuff on stoicism because you know
I'm very active in stoic communities and
I knew there's a lot of people asking
these same sort of questions so did
quite a few of those and I'm quite happy
with how they've turned out so that was
the month of of March alright so what is
coming up in April I know a lot of
people want to know about that so we've
got a number of events most of them are
actually online when I think about we
only have two local events I'll start
with those first so on Thursday the 12th
at 7:00 p.m. we continue our worlds of
speculative fiction by looking at L
Sprague de Kamp's completed chanter
stories these are very interesting and
they they use a a syllogism vehicle to
get themselves into alternate worlds
there's a lot of stuff to talk about you
know about the feasibility of this in
terms of philosophical themes and then
much later in the month again we have
our MKE stoic fellowship
that's the Thursday the 26th at 6 p.m.
Shorewood public library we're still
going through Seneca we're pretty deep
in the letters at this point and so
that's that's been very enjoyable so
we'll talk about that and then I've got
quite a few you know online events I
always have philosophy pop-ups but I
only announce those to my patreon
supporters ahead of time so if you if
you you're interested in becoming a
supporter and finding out when the
pop-ups will will occur I let them know
at the beginning of the month and
everybody else finds out the day of the
things that we do have on the calendar
on the the 11th at 5 p.m. we'll have our
half-hour Haegele public Q&A and
discussion so if you've got any
questions confusions concerns about
Hegel German idealism even philosophy in
general you're welcome to show up at
that that is something that's under
written by my patreon supporters on the
14th
it's a Saturday at 1:00 p.m. I will have
the AMA that's asking me anything
session and so that's exactly what it
sounds like you do want to get to that
early because the questions pile up and
I I'm finding that there are so many of
them that I can always answer the ones I
have at the start but towards the end I
don't always get to to all of them and
then on the 21st at 2:00 p.m. I will
have my philosophy chat for my patreon
supporters this is a one-hour session
where they get to videoconference with
me and get to talk you know ask me
questions about whatever they're working
on or thinking about and I do my best to
try to respond to them so that's that's
events what else have we got going on
still teaching of course the world views
and values class from Maris College
Online
again if you're interested in that you
can click on the there to be up in that
corner
you can click on the card to find out
about it and you can you can take the
class if you want to online you won't do
the same homework as the students and it
won't be for credit but you know that's
that's the nature of that I have a lot
of consulting work lined up a lot of
tutorial sessions lined up I actually
picked up a few new clients and some
philosophical counseling and coaching
including some of it locally here in in
Milwaukee and I'm hoping to get to some
of the writing that I wasn't able to do
last month in particular in my blogs you
know and and starting to spread out the
writing and in other forums so we'll see
how that works out
I am slated to be in a few interviews
there's some some other interviews that
should be coming out later this month
for podcast episodes so you might want
to stay tuned to my facebook page or to
you know reason IO
and you'll see me posting about them or
you can watch or exes do you know I TK
to every once in a while I do a roundup
on there but a lot of the month is
devoted to sort of like trying to get
myself back on track you know doing kind
of spring cleaning not just of the place
but also of the desktop you know and the
projects that I've got going on so
that's going to be taking a bit of time
well the last thing I'll talk about is
is videos
what do we have lined up this month so
I'm going to be doing a good bit of core
concept videos and like I said I do have
to finish up with Cicero's on duties I
just have a little bit of stuff from
book one on temperance to do and then I
I did promise to do some core concept
videos on Heidegger's introduction of
being in time I know people have been
waiting for them for a while so I will
be working on those but I think I also
want to do some core concepts stuff that
you know
people are gonna probably need before
the end of the semester and so I think
what I'm gonna do is some stuff on
Descartes some stuff on Plato you know
gaps where I haven't done things and I
don't know I might do some walk or some
Hume you know I got to think about this
there's so many things that I haven't
done core concepts on that they couldn't
really use that that treatment I'm gonna
do some more Q&A videos most of which I
think will focus on stoicism but maybe
some of them will be broader those are
looking at sort of common questions sort
of things that keep popping up over and
over again that I think people might be
helped out I need to get on some book
reviews as well a doctor say oh there's
honest reviews series so you can look
for some of those coming out this month
I'm also gonna try to do some some of
the dr. Sadler soapbox thing there's
plenty of things to talk about it just
wasn't able to get to it last month I
have another interview video coming out
this month and I'm gonna try to do some
more interviews depending on people's
schedules and then finally you know I've
got a few personal videos that people
have been asking for that I think I will
I will do as well so that is you know
the plan it's pretty ambitious we'll see
how much of it gets done like I said I'm
still you know sick so I so I have to
pay close attention to how much time I'm
devoting to this and that and really how
much energy sometimes I just wind up so
wiped out depending on what I'm doing
but I'm you know I did manage to get
some exercise in it last week I'm gonna
be going tonight and working out as well
and trying to get back on track this
this week so last thing that I'll
mention you know if you're interested in
in tutorials or philosophical counseling
go to the website reason IO and you can
see what it is that I do you can also
email me directly at Greg at reason I
out
come and if you're looking for somebody
to come speak you know if you're a
longtime fan you know how many different
topics I can talk about it so if you've
got a group organization institution
that's looking for a speaker or you've
got a conference and you're looking for
somebody to come in and give a keynote
address if it's philosophy related I'm
happy to come in and do that again that
you can reach me Greg at at reason IO
comm that's the best way to get that
going
hope all of you have a great and
productive month and maybe I'll see some
of you at the online events
you